Joanna, thank you so much for coming in
and going through my 23andme report with, with us
and with all of you out there. Is that
pretty much all there is to the 23andme report?
>> No, we just scratched the surface. there are all kinds
of tools that you could use to go deeper into your health
and deeper into your ancestry. and one in particular, a tool called
DNA Relatives allows you to connect with people with whom you share
DNA, people in the 23andme database. And you can
discover new relatives and really flesh out your family tree.
>> Now that sounds like a really cool feature. And we're
going to use it in lesson 11. So all of you
should stay tuned because we're going to discover if Sterling Tadlock,
our adopted individual, can find any biological family members of his own.